Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich habe mir überlegt, vielleicht sollten wir auch mal unsere Kapazitäten am DEzix äh steigern.
Ja, ich finde, so eine Verzwanzigfachung und der Kapazitäten würde uns gut zu Gesicht stehen.
Politik, eins, drei, eins, heute habe ich's richtig gesagt.
Ich bin's, Tim und äh ich begrüße euch äh alle hier beim Zuhören von Logboot Netzpolitik, eurem Lieblingspodcast. Da, wo die Dystopie noch äh Spaß macht,
Und Lidos, wie geht's dir so?
Es geht mir voran. Ich bin ein bisschen müde, ja.
Bist du müde bist du? So früher, so früh am Morgen. Ja, wir nehmen.
Ja, ja, bei dir ist noch früh, das stimmt, ja.
Ja, stimmt.
Bei mir ist die Woche ja schon vorbei.
Ja, ja, so ist das. Mit ein bisschen Feedback anfangen.
Ja, sollen wir äh haben wir aber also ich habe überlegt zu dem Feedback am Anfang so Musik, wer noch zu früh, ne, weil wir kurz davor ja schon Musik hatten.
Ja das hängt ja auch immer was vom Feedback ab, ne, ähm ob man dann so eine.
Also so so ein Gitarrenriff, was dann so in Feedback übergeht so ist schlecht, ne.
Keinen Gitarrenriff, das machen nur amerikanische,
Die müssen die ganze Zeit immer so Rock'n'Roll spielen und überhaupt so Gitarrenmusik und und und Radio-Jingles echt nicht. Sind ja hier in Deutschland. Wir machen Techno äh da habe ich aber jetzt gerade nix äh nix parat.
Techno habe ich, da könnte man was machen.
Da müssen wir, müssen wir halt mal unsere äh kreative Hörerschaft, die in der Lage ist, da passendes äh Klanggewitter zu erzeugen, vielleicht mal bitten, gute Ideen zu haben. Wobei ich jetzt auch nicht,
dass wir die Sendung total überladen sollten mit dem ganzen Kram.
Nee, ich bin also ich bin echt nicht, weil das das wäre halt einfach zu nah an dem an dem Intro. Ich glaube, so am Anfang und am Ende mal ab und an mal ein bisschen Musik kann man machen, aber irgendwie so bei jedem Themenwechsel irgendwie so eine.
An Thementrainer, noch so ein.
Du ja einmal hattest, das fand ich sehr schön. Da war dir bei, bei Raumzeit, da da hattest du, hast du ja auch immer auf der Remote irgendwie so einen Knopf gedrückt, wenn das Thema sich.
Dann habe ich so einen so einen Schneideton äh gehabt und den habe ich dann irgendwie in die Sendung mit rausgerinnert.
Gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ja
Ton war nicht schlecht.
Ja, der Ton, den habe ich, das habe ich deshalb gemacht, damit ich, wenn ich die Sendung abhöre,
merke, wenn 'ne Stelle kommt wo ich 'ne Kapitelmarke gesetzt habe, dass ich die nicht verpasse
Sonst ja die ganze Zeit hingucken muss. Ja genau und dann wie das immer so ist mit diesen Workflows da, das muss ich alles erstmal fünfmal muss das gegen die Wand gefahren werden, bevor das sitzt und das war dann halt so ein,
die Wand fallen. Ich hab's dann auch gleich beim nächsten Mal nochmal gemacht, also.
Super, wie hier, hier schneit es ja auch regelmäßig.
Wie die Profis hier. Ja.
Ja, vergiss bloß nicht gleich das äh wegzuschneiden, wo wir über die Musik drüber gelabert haben.
Das wird sowieso grade wieder beklagt, wie niedrig doch die äh Podcastqualität in Deutschland ist und gelabert wird.
Soll man Musik-Podcast machen oder was?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Es muss alles jetzt irgendwie geschnitten, gefeatured und und und völlig überdreht sein. Ich ich äh halte mich da jetzt mal zurück. Ich
kann in dem Zusammenhang nur auf eine Folge in einem äh anderen meiner äh Podcasts verweisen, die vielleicht manche schon gehört haben. Jetzt darf ich hier auch mal was
Plaggen und zwar die letzte Sendung äh ähm der Lautsprecherpodcast Nummer fünfzehn, LS null fuffzehn, der Sender bin ich
wo ich mich mit Podcast Veteran, Philipp Banso unterhalten habe. Und das ist äh sehr interessant, weil ja da auch sehr viel über wie USA das macht und und und was was so hier in Deutschland gehen könnte, unterhalten haben
Kann ich nur jedem ans Herz legen, wer so ein bisschen Interesse hat auf der Meterebene der Meter eben zu surfen.
Also das finde ich ja lustig. Also Philipp und du sind ja wirklich die Podcast-Veteran, wo auf wen von beiden habt ihr euch denn geeinigt, wenn der Titel nur der Podcast bin ich? Äh ist, lautet oder geht das Unentschieden aus oder.
Podcast der Sender bin ich.
Der Sender, ja, bist ja trotzdem.
Wir haben ja jetzt keinen Battle gemacht.
Aber ich habe noch nie, ich hatte, ich hatte noch nie Philipp zu Gast. Also er hatte mich zwar schon dreimal zu Gast und auch mal als Co-Moderator und wir haben ja auch Projekte zusammen gemacht, aber ich hatte ihn selber noch nie zu Gast. Das war jetzt insofern ein Novum nach zehn Jahren,
Und das Ganze habe ich halt deshalb gemacht, weil er ja gerade dieses neue Projekt startet, der Sender und das war dann,
sozusagen der, der, der Anlass, mal auch ein Review zu machen über
A, was er halt überhaupt gemacht hat, weil ich glaube, das wissen viele auch gar nicht. Und B
auch äh so seine Erkenntnisse äh über das Format, zumal er ja eben auch tiefe Einblicke hat, in wie es im normalen Radio, also Deutschlandfunk und Deutschlandradio et cetera äh abläuft und,
Darüber hinaus eben jetzt auch noch eigene ähm
verfolgt mit dieser Genossenschaftsidee für so ein Sendeinstitut. Also alles sehr interessant, schönes Gespräch.
Da freue ich mich drauf. Das ähm das möchte ich, da da bin ich wirklich dran interessiert, da freue ich mich drauf. Das ist schön, den höre ich mir heute Abend an. Da freue ich mich drauf.
Schön.
Ja, der äh Küchenradio ist ja da noch an der Stelle zu erwähnen, finde ich ja auch ein sehr, sehr geiles äh Podcastformat von Phillip. Das ist auch, glaube ich, der der Podcast mit den meisten,
Folgen überhaupt in Deutschland, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht so genau, aber ist auf jeden Fall äh wenn's eine Top Ten gäbe, ist der auf jeden Fall da drin. Also die letzte Folge ist dreihunderteinundachtzig. Das haben jetzt so
viele nicht hinbekommen. Es gibt natürlich auch so ein paar Podcaster und so, die auch schon absurde Zahlen erreicht haben. Wobei ich denke, wenn man das mal nach Stunden rechnet und so
Also wer hat sozusagen am meisten Stunden Podcast produziert? Da könnte ich mir dann wiederum ganz äh gute Plätze vorne ausrechnen.
Das auf jeden Fall. Das auf jeden Fall. Aber da ist Philipp auch ein harter Konkurrent.
Ist er auf jeden Fall immer gewesen und äh wir haben auch immer gegenseitig gegenseitig unsere Messer aneinander geschärft.
Ja, super, also ja, macht ihr schärft ihr mal weiter, Hauptsache ich komme dabei nicht unter die Räder, um mal noch weiter die die äh Metaphern hier zu.
Genau und äh für für die geneigten Logbuch äh Netzpolitikhörer, die äh sich jetzt ohnehin schon wundern, warum wir uns irgendwie über sowas unterhalten, gebe ich dann gleich mal einen Küchenradio-Tipp, auch wenn ich die selber noch nicht gehört habe, aber hier ein äh das unserer Sendung, nämlich der Ulf Bürmeier, der war auch äh jüngst bei Küchenradio zu Gast Küchenradio.
Ein halbes Jahr her.
Achtundsiebzig, na, ist ja egal, haben wir noch nie erwähnt. Äh mit.
Bei uns mal zu Gast. Sebastian.
Man spricht das Burmeier aus, aber er schreibt sich egal.
Natürlich war Roll zu Gast, das habe ich ja gerade gesagt, aber äh deswegen, ja, der Bezug, ja, aber da erzählt er halt überhaupt was anderes, nämlich wie so seine Zeit in den USA war, darüber hat er ja bei uns nicht gesprochen.
War auch eine ganz nette Sendung.
Genau. Gut, genug. Feedback-Time.
Nö. Nö, ich finde, man kann noch mehr planken.
Hast du noch was zu.
Ja, ich habe ein ein sehr interessanten Podcast gehört, darauf bin ich aufmerksam geworden, weil äh mich weil auf Twitter Leute erwähnt haben, dass äh dass einer der Sprecher dort so klingen würde, wie ich,
Was? Was was tatsächlich stimmt, ja? Der hat eine sehr ähnliche Stimme, aber äh mit dem habe ich nichts zu tun. Ähm und zwar ist das ein Podcast von ähm Metronaut.
Aber der Podcast heißt Metrolaut und die hatten den Frank zu Gast und haben sich über ähm äh über Verschwörungstheorien unterhalten,
Das war, fand ich auch ganz äh ganz interessant, das Gespräch. Die haben sowieso äh immer ganz, ganz gute Podcast. Metrolaut erscheint nur sehr selten, aber so meine Lieblingsfolge davon ist es jetzt auch schon bald ein Jahr alt mit dem,
wohlklingenden Titel Züge anlacken,
Fand ich sehr schön, mitm Graffiti-Sprüher. Das hat mich die hat mich nachhaltig äh auch äh interessiert die Folge,
Damit können wir jetzt auch echt die aufhören weiterzuempfehlen, oder?
Denke ich auch. Jetzt aber Feedback.
Aber wusstest du, dass die Amis gar nicht auf dem Mond gelandet sind?
Oh Mann, dazu habe ich auch schon einen Podcast gemacht, soll ich denn jetzt auch nochmal placken?
Also, na, kommen wir zum Feedback,
man darf aus der Ur-Haft straffrei ausbrechen. Man darf, glaube ich, sogar aus dem Knast straffrei ausbrechen, solange man auf dem Weg keine Werte umnitet, schrieb dir Marius via E-Mail, haben wir aber auch
mehrere Kommentare gehabt. Ich habe nämlich in der letzten Folge gesagt, wenn ich aus dem Knast ausbreche, wird meine Aufenthaltsdauer dort auch verlängert.
Stimmt nicht. Also eigentlich cool, ne? Ähm.
Das Bedürfnis nach Freiheit wird in Deutschland als grundlegendes, menschliches Bedürfnis und damit Grundrecht eingestuft. Eine Flucht aus dem Justizvollzug ist daher nicht strafbar.
Um dies dennoch justiziabel zu bekommen, werden Begleitumstände verfolgt, zum Beispiel der Diebstahl von Anstaltskleidung, Sachbeschädigung von Gittern, Widerstand gegen äh Bedienstete oder Körperverletzung. Also man kommt man muss schon irgendwie sehr slick sein
um da wirklich vollständig straffrei rauszukommen, aber da rauszukommen. Also sich steht erstmal nicht unter Strafe.
Wer sich äh wer sich nackt durch Gitter zwängt und heimlich entkommt, handelt rechtskonform.
Außer, dass er dann nachher nackt auf der Straße steht und da dann wahrscheinlich gegen irgendeinen Jugendschutzgesetz oder sowas verstößt, die haben ja in der Regel haben wir das das öffentliche Leben ganz gut abgedeckt mit Gesetzen ähm,
aber OK das war ein Hinweis, dann die Videos von Barrett Brown gibt's noch
und sie sind sehr langatmig, das könnte aber auch sein, dass ich mir das einfach nur als Notiz hingeschrieben habe, weil ich habe mir das dann mal angeguckt und das heißt also ein sehr ähm.
Ja, also man kann sich diese Videos anschauen von Barrett Brown, wie er dann
von jahrelanger Heroinsucht erzählt und und in mehreren Folgen dann eben von von seinem Hass auf diesen FBI Beamten und allen anderen Mist in seinem Leben irgendwie redet, ähm das finde ich schon sehr, sehr ähm.
Bedenklich wiederum überhaupt, dass man.
Menschen für so was bestraft, der sich da wirklich äh ein Karriereende herbeigeredet hat und ähm ja, das ist also das kann man sich eigentlich auch gar nicht angucken. Ja, aber äh fand ich ganz hm.
Ja, äh also die gibt's noch, weil ich ja gesagt habe, die werden wahrscheinlich aus dem Internet verschwunden, aber das äh aus dem Internet verschwindet nichts.
Und.
Nicht das, von dem man möchte, das ist äh verschwindet.
Ja, ich habe jetzt gerade noch mal irgendwie sowas zu diesem äh Recht auf Vergessen. Das war so eine der letzten Meldungen, die es nicht mehr in die Sendung geschafft haben, weil wir die Sendung jetzt machen, ähm gelesen.
Wer weiß, vielleicht verschwinden doch mehr Sachen,
aus dem Internet als man will oder die, die man möchte, dann doch oder kommt ja auch immer drauf an, wer was will. Keine Ahnung,
Na und dann gab's noch ein äh ein noch eine,
Debatte in den Kommentaren, ob denn nun ähm so äh quasi.
Man Anbietern vertrauen soll, die Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselungsmethoden anbieten, die man nicht vollständig selber unter Kontrolle hat. Also
darunter fallen dann natürlich, weil man da mit keiner Form in keiner Form in Kontakt mit dem Schlüssel kommt, äh darunter fällt, wenn Google es denn umsetzen wird, wovon ich
wo wo im Moment noch die Zeichen draufstehen, solche Java Skript äh ähm
Zaubereien, um irgendwie ähm Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung da rein zu bringen. Ähm ja, das also um da kurz zu,
da ist eigentlich nur das zu zu sagen, was ich eigentlich letzte Woche schon in der Sendung gesagt habe, die reine Leere der IT-Sicherheit, die vertreten wir jetzt irgendwie als äh
aufgeklärte Community irgendwie seit zwanzig Jahren und man kann sehen wohin uns das gebracht hat,
worum es hier aber geht, ist eben Methoden auch für Anbieter, die Niability zu geben für,
vergangene Nachrichten oder für zukünftige Nachrichten richten. Und vor allem darauf zu sorgen, dass dafür zu sorgen.
Dass irgendwie ähm Geheimdienste nicht mehr einfach irgendwo ein Kabel dran halten und sofort alles haben.
Und natürlich kann man sich dann da hinstellen und sagen, nee, nee, nee, aber wenn Google dann irgendwie einen anderen äh Java Skript und so, dann kann man das ja immer noch brechen, ja, kann man. Aber äh das finde ich auch ein sehr, sehr mutige,
Äußerung von jemandem, der irgendwie einen Computer benutzt, der sowieso irgendwie von zwanzig äh Geheimdiensten der Welt geordnt werden kann. Ähm plus von dem Werbenetzwerk und man sowieso irgendwie jeden Scheiß darauf installiert. Also man kommt bei IT-Sicherheit,
vom hundertsten ins tausendste und das ist ja auch, ich meine, genau diese Gedanken zur Anwendung zu bringen ist ja das, was ich auch jeden Tag beruflich tue,
Ähm und da bringe ich natürlich auch genau diese Einwände zur Sprache. Man muss nur aufpassen, dass man sich eben,
man dann nicht irgendwie im Nichtstun verharrt, sondern dass man sich eben die Schritte äh raussucht, die ähm signifikante Verbesserungen für äh große Angriffsflächen ähm.
Bieten. Und da gehört's natürlich zu, wenn solche Anbieter solche Verfahren jetzt an anbringen, ja? Wenn sie die jetzt wieder back dorn oder dann auf auf Straf äh,
auf auf irgendwelche Warrens oder Befehle dann doch wieder Einzelpersonen angreifen oder die die Schlüssel rausrücken schön und gut. Das Entscheidende ist aber, dass man erstmal die Masse der Bevölkerung schützt und deswegen sind solche Initiativen,
natürlich zu bevorzugen und zu und gut zu heißen, vor allem weil sie Nutzer überhaupt mal äh überhaupt erst mal in die Richtung
dieser Thematik bringen, ja? Also dieses mit dem wir bringen PGP bei und alles andere ist Quatsch, da kann man, glaube ich, ähm bis auf die Wenigen,
ähm.
Beachtlichen, aber immer noch sehr äh zahlenmäßig sehr geringen Erfolge der Kryptopartys äh sagen, dass es jetzt,
wirklich die letzten zwanzig Jahre uns, uns nicht an den Punkt gebracht haben, an den wir eigentlich hätten kommen sollen als als Gesellschaft. Und insofern denke ich,
äh muss man sich von dieser fundamentalistischen Position, äh in der man sich ja weigert, die Menschen dort abzuholen, wo sie stehen, leider verabschieden,
ohne sie aus den, aus den Augen zu verlieren, aber ähm,
wie gesagt, so diese reine Leere habe ich hier in den Shownotes auch äh absichtlich mit zwei E geschrieben, statt mit EH.
Ja, ist auch so ein bisschen so, als als als ob man immer von jedem erwarten würde mit so einer ähm
Himalaya tauglichen, winderausrüstung vor die Tür zu gehen, wenn's mal kalt ist, weil äh nur das kann einen wirklich in allen Situationen vor dem Erfrieren schützen, aber wenn die Alternative ist, draußen nackt rumzulaufen, dann ist da vielleicht so ein normaler Wintermantel vielleicht auch schon mal ganz hilfreich und ich glaube, darum geht's so ein bisschen.
Genau, das ist ein sehr schöner Vergleich, den werde ich in meinen in mein kleines Buch der guten Vergleiche schreiben, die ich irgendwie andauernd bringen muss zu jedem Thema. Das finde ich ein guter, ist ein guter Vergleich. Komm mal ein kleines Buch der Vergleiche. Habe ich.
Freut mich. Und durch mein Feedback.
Es sei denn, du hast noch Feedback.
Nee, ich habe kein Feedback. Also keins, was du nicht schon erwähnt hättest, sagen wir es mal so.
Vielleicht hast du einen Nachtrag.
Nö, ich habe den jetzt, also ich hatte ja schon einen Nachtrag.
Aber das nächste Thema hast du mit Nachtrag überschrieben.
Ach so, äh ach so, ja, den äh Nachtrag, Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich die Brücke natürlich nicht so ganz mitbekommen, weil ich hier das falsche Fenster offen hatte,
Genau, der Nachtrag ist also, wir hatten ja äh letzte Woche das schöne äh Gespräch mit äh Katar ähm über äh TTIP,
Ein längerer Schwerpunkt
Würde das ja immer ganz gerne äh machen. Da gibt's jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel Neues. Wir sind nur im im Nachgang ein paar äh Artikel aufgefallen, die äh in dem Zusammenhang äh vielleicht nochmal bemerkenswert sind.
Einerseits berichtete der Tagesspiegel
drüber, dass die USA halt dann doch ähm so ein bisschen äh beunruhigt äh ist und diese ganzen Trend zur äh Offenlegung von Verhandlungsdokumenten versucht zu torpedieren, wie es nur äh irgendwie möglich ist. Also,
auch so direkt zuständige Mitarbeiter der EU-Regierung sollen also nur so ein Ausnahmefällen, da äh Zugang bekommen. Man fragt sich halt wirklich, was das was das soll. Und ist ja auch sehr interessant zu sehen, dass
auch genau das derzeit also nicht nur das, aber dass das so eine der Sachen ist, die in der Öffentlichkeit auch tatsächlich mit ähm
zunehmenden Naserümpfen,
zur Kenntnis genommen werden, weil es gibt ja verschiedene Ebenen der Debatte. Viel geht's in diesen ganzen Lebensmittel, Verbraucherschutz rein, weil wir wissen, dass ne, das äh bringt ja die Gemüter mehr in Wallung, als wenn man sich jetzt über Netzpolitik oder Urheberrecht unterhält.
Und ähm ja, was ja auch äh passiert ist, ist, dass in Griechenland äh
da neue linke Popstars in die Regierung äh gekommen sind, die ja schon eine ganze Menge Welle gemacht haben und wo es halt äh derzeit ja im Wesentlichen um die,
neue,
oder möglicherweise neue Aushandlungen der Modalitäten der äh griechischen Konjunkturgesundung und Schuldentilgung äh geht. Ähm
meldet Euro aktiv DE, das ist so ein europäisches äh Nachrichtenmagazin, also was ich konkret auf Brüssel
konzentriert, was wir im Übrigen hier auch mal erwähnen sollten, weil was ich mit immer gemacht habe, ist das ja auch so immer mal so Quellen genannt haben
Da war auch eure Aktiv mal dabei, weil die äh veröffentlichen nämlich alles auf Englisch, auf Französisch und Deutsch.
Das heißt, selbst wer jetzt so europäische Nachrichten mal verfolgen möchte und dann immer das Problem hat, dass wenn man was Deutsches gelesen hat, dann das nicht so auf Englisch oder in anderen Sprachen teilen kann
Da ist man also bei auch aktiv äh ganz gut unterwegs, die sind recht informiert, die fokussieren halt auf Europa
und äh da kommt halt auch dieser Artikel her und der meint halt, das hat einer der Minister, ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, äh wer das jetzt genau war, auf jeden Fall meinten sie halt so, ja, also sie würden auf gar keinen Fall.
Für TTIP stimmen. Weil, weil sie da halt einfach, und das haben wir ja hier ausreichend
er wiegt einfach da das nicht sehen, ne? Ist ja so eine neue linke Welle, die da jetzt so ein bisschen äh scheint,
getreten worden zu sein. Man weiß noch nicht so richtig, wie weit das trägt.
Ob die jetzt überhaupt soweit ähm erfolgreich sind. Aber äh so oder so, ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, wie das auf der Abstimmungsebene läuft, aber ich glaube, so eine gewisse Veto äh Macht haben sie schon,
noch sind sie ja Mitglied. Muss man sehen.
Ja. Das haben sie das haben sie noch nicht abgesagt, ne. Sonst haben die eigentlich, die haben ja echt mal ganz gut reinen Tisch gemacht da in Griecheland.
Ja, mal gucken. Ich meine, ein Schäubler, dass ich äh ja eine eine blutige Nase geholt, aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dass die
dass sie ganz populär sind derzeit noch äh in in Griechenland, weil sie halt nicht einen anderen Ton setzen, ne? Also ich meine, jetzt haben sie als erstes mal so die ganze Ministerutoflotte verkauft,
Unter anderem sind siebenhundertfünfzigtausend Euro, BMW und so und fahren halt irgendwie Taxi, Straßenbahn und äh der Finanzminister fliegt halt Economy class durch Europa, so.
So ein schönes Foto oder so in der Economy Class umringt von Journalisten irgendwie sitzt, aber halt so ganz normal.
Oder am Rand?
Am Gang. Nee, aber das ist schon ist schon eine coole Sau. Der fährt ja auch immer irgendwie mitm ähm,
Motorrad durch die Gegend kann ich übrigens sehr empfehlen. Ich habe die letzten Tage ähm mir mal so auf YouTube ein paar Vorträge von ihm angeschaut, weil äh noch so aus einer Zeit, wo nicht absehbar war, dass er mal äh griechischer Minister äh nicht Präsident, aber Minister werden würde,
und der hat ja schon wirklich eine sehr dedizierte Meinung zu diesem gesamten äh Komplex und äh,
kann auch sehr gut argumentieren, spricht auch hervorragend Englisch, also eine eine spannende Personalie, ja, ich bin da äh,
will da jetzt gar nicht irgendso eine hm,
bin da jetzt nicht Fanboy, ich finde das nur nur spannend, ähm wie jetzt auf einmal diese ganze
äh Diskussion auch um Gerechtigkeit innerhalb Europas und Solidarität da äh neu aufbricht und äh gerade Deutschland halt ein bisschen schlecht da steht. Wir sehen aber auch, dass halt EZB,
und andere Kanäle jetzt natürlich auch ordentlich dagegen hauen und äh ist so ein bisschen Clash of the Cultures an der Stelle
und ähm ja, ist äh zumindest mal eine Debatte, die ja von so Gruppen wie Attack, et cetera im Prinzip ja schon seit Jahrzehnten geführt wird, aber die jetzt auf einmal auf so eine äh politische Ebene gehoben wird und
Das kann nur gut sein, diese Diskussion auch mal zu führen.
Ja, ähm ich weiß zwar nicht, ob die gerade wirklich eine Diskussion führen oder ob das, ob da nicht schon der offene Krieg ist, aber äh ich werde, ich bin da auf jeden Fall auch sehr gespannt, äh ob der Entwicklungen.
Genau,
Andere Entwicklungen gibt es in den äh USA und zwar steht da demnächst nämlich die Abstimmung über Netzneutralität äh innerhalb des äh FCC an,
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie übersetzt man den FCC am besten.
Ja, aber das ist hier so ein bisschen wie unsere ähm wie heißt denn das hier bei uns in Deutschland.
Bienetz A.
Den Bundesnetzagentur, genau, die übernimmt so ein bisschen die Rolle. Also sozusagen da, wo es eben darum geht, konkret die Regeln aufzustellen für die Telekommunikationsunternehmen
Und da äh ging's ja schon lange hin und her, da gab's ja auch viele äh böse Vorwürfe, dass der Chef ja da irgendwie von comcast äh kam er sogar daher oder ich weiß es ja immer so ganz genau
und ähm das ist lange Zeit einfach nicht danach aussah, als ob sich das äh zum Guten entwickeln äh würde, ja?
Ich finde nur noch ganz kurz äh die Geschichte fing ja noch früher an, wenn ich das noch kurz einwerfen darf,
denn es gab in den USA ja schon mal von der FCC eine Netzneutralitätsregulation,
und die wurde zweitausendvierzehn Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtete von Horizon vor einem Berufungsgericht weggeklagt.
Und der äh der das Argument der von Horizon, mit dem sie vor diesem Berufungsgericht Recht bekommen haben, war, dass die rechtliche Grundlage,
für ein Einmischen der FCC gefehlt habe in diesen in den Bereich des Internets. Die haben also quasi,
also deren Argument war, ihr dürft die gar nicht hier, Internet, habt ihr nichts mit zu tun.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Genau darauf, deswegen habe ich dich an der Stelle gerade unterbrochen, auf genau darauf will der Wheeler jetzt reagieren, indem er sagt, ja okay, dann stellen wir das Internet rechtlich dem Telefonnetz gleich.
Und damit ist es dann ein Universaldienst, der unter eine strikte Kontrolle der FCC gehört.
Sorry und darüber wollen Sie jetzt am sechsundzwanzigsten Februar abstimmen.
Mhm,
Ja, da gibt's dann auch entsprechende äh Aufmerksamkeitsgenerierungen. Die IFF hat so einen Internetcountdown gestartet. Das ist jetzt zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt gerade nochmal zwanzig Tage
also am sechsundzwanzigsten Februar findet das Ganze statt und parallel entwickelt sich dazu natürlich auch 'ne entsprechende Debatte hier in Europa,
Inwiefern das da direkt davon getriggert ist. Mir ist allerdings was Interessantes aufgefallen und zwar unser äh Vizepräsident, der äh europäischen,
und äh außerdem der äh zuständige,
Kommissar für digitalen Binnenmarkt, ja?
Also nicht hier Herr Öttinger, sondern der Andros äh ein Estnischer äh Politiker und übrigens auch Chemiker.
Also Wissenschaftler, darauf wollte ich hinaus. Ähm der äh ist ja schon so am Anfang ein bisschen aufgefallen,
Als äh ihn da Julia Reeder äh früh ähm dazu gebracht hat, da äh ich glaube so was war das äh auf Twitter irgendwie äh Stellung zu nehmen et cetera und das hat er irgendwie alles ganz gut.
Angenommen und machte früh den Eindruck, dass er ähm sagen wir mal ein ein der Debatte recht empfänglicher Mensch zu sein scheint,
und der hat auch einen Blog.
Und besonders bemerkenswert fand ich, dass er auf diesem Blog jetzt äh einen Gastkommentar hat von äh niemand Geringeren als,
Bekannt natürlich als der Erfinder des World Wide Web, worin sich eben
Ist nicht anders zu erwarten war absolut hinter
eine klare Netzneutralitätsregelung gestellt hat, also er möchte natürlich weiterhin, dass das Web äh offen ist und so neutral wie es nur irgendwie geht und
Na ja, das ist ähm schon eine interessante Positionierung an der Stelle. Man könnte es dir vorstellen, dass in äh Frau Merkels Block
was es nicht gibt. So ein Gastkommentar erscheinen würde, so,
Nee, können wir nicht, aber findet statt und das fand ich äh bemerkenswert. Link ist in den Shownotes.
Genau und nochmal auf die USA zurückzukommen, dass wir also dass dieser Umschwenker des äh Herrn Wheeler ähm,
den hiftet sich jetzt, die heftet sich, die IFF wahrscheinlich auch zurecht. Ähm,
als einen großen Erfolg des der Community an. Team Internet beginnt der Artikel, ähm denn es ist schon so, dass also was USA und Netzneutalität angeht. Da wurde jetzt echt so dieses gesamte letzte dreiviertel Jahr
wirklich die Trommel gerührt. Die haben das Thema echt ähm aufrecht erhalten, ne,
und ähm auch diese den Weeler da in seiner Position ähm bekehrt. Ähm er sagt,
oder er kündigt an, also,
ich will dafür sorgen, dass wir regulatorisch zuständig sind, darüber stimmt dann die Kommission aus irgendwelchen Gründen selber ab und dann sagt er ähm,
Das und dann sagt er, dann kommen wir mit unseren Regeln, ja? Und Internet Protection, die FCC.
Ähm und zentral wird es ihm natürlich dann darum gehen ähm.
Dafür zu sorgen, dass ähm,
keine Beeinträchtigung oder Blockierung von rechtmäßigen Inhalten durch
stattfinden darf. Rechtmäßig haben die da immer noch drin stehen, das ist am Ende alles, was die äh was dann die die Urheberrechts,
verwertenden Industrien wirklich interessiert, ne? Rechtmäßig heißt, ein nicht rechtmäßiger Inhalt kann natürlich trotzdem noch blockiert werden,
Da will sich die FCC nicht einmischen. Also so diese ganzen Uhr hierbei rechtssperren und so was sind sind ausgenommen, Terror, Propaganda, Videos oder was man sonst noch irgendwie verbieten
kann, ähm Ausbruchanleitung aus der Urhaft, nein, war ein Scherz, aber äh also man kann irgendwie ähm sie wollen quasi illegale Inhalte immer noch äh verbieten können, aber für diesen,
für das zentrale Marktargument des des Ausbremsen von Konkurrenten oder des des Erheben von doppelten äh Brückenzoll
zwischen Anbietern und Konsumenten sollte dann schon ein entscheidender Riegel vorgeschrieben äh vorgeschoben sein.
Und wenn ich mich nicht täusche, sogar für äh für äh Kabel und kabelloses Internet.
Das war weil da bin ich jetzt vorsichtig, das ist eine Sache, wo ich mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher bin.
Ja, vom Saulus äh zum Paulus äh in dem Zusammenhang können wir auch noch erwähnen, dass ja sogar unsere Datenschützerin, nachdem sie jetzt zwei Jahre darüber nachgedacht hat, wohl der Meinung ist, dass sie Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht so eine tolle Idee ist.
Also überhaupt so die erste Wortmeldung, die so von ihr äh bekannt geworden ist, seitdem sie in diesem Amte ist, aber äh immerhin, ne? Also das scheint durchaus zu funktionieren noch, dass man manche Leute mit Argumenten äh erreichen kann. Das äh ist,
gewisser Hinsicht Schocking, aber schön auch.
Ja, kurz, ich kann das kurz bestätigen, also es soll vor allem auch für mobiles Breitband, also vom vom für, sorry, für äh Mobilnetze gelten,
Bei der ersten Netzneutralitätsregulation war das nämlich nicht so. Da haben sie eine große Netzneutralitätsregulation hingeschrieben und haben gesagt, alles hier, Internet und so weiter.
Aber mobil ist ja nicht Internet.
Mobil bei Mobilgeld eine andere Anforderung und daher diese ganzen Regeln nicht. Wenn man das im Hinblick auf die Zukunft betrachtet, ähm ist es natürlich,
Problem, wenn mobile Netze ausgeschlossen werden. Denn man sieht ja schon, dass sich das alles zu diesen mobilen Netzen hinbewegt. Ja, in.
Ja, bestes Beispiel, der neue Telekom-Hybrid-Anschluss, der so eine Melange aus DSL und äh LTE ist, also die Unterschiede, die sind.
Und andere Länder,
in denen die Entwicklungen nicht so schnell vorangegangen ist, wie in in westlichen Staaten, die überspringen ja im Prinzip diese gesamte Zuhause, Internet und ein,
PC haben Phase und landen jetzt so im Zeitalter der äh Tablets und äh,
und Smartphones,
ja? Da gibt's, da gab es nie Landline Internet. Gut, die sind jetzt auch nicht von der US-Netzneutralitätsregulation betroffen, aber ähm die Entwicklung Mobile ist the future, ja, kann ich.
Ja, Afrika vor allem, ne, also wo auch,
wo auch Landline, also wo das auch durchaus mal probiert wurde, ist aber einfach keinerlei ähm Zukunft hatte, weil jedes Stück Kupfer, was da in irgendeiner Erde vergraben wird, einfach zehn Minuten später wieder ausgebuddelt wurde. Ähm
Da hätte dann theoretisch zwar Glasfaser mehr geholfen, weil das kann man eben nicht so gewinnbringend verkaufen wie Kupfer, aber äh daran war halt dann zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht dran zu denken. Und jetzt ist natürlich mit LTE und dann eben auch so mit Fift Generation
Internet sieht halt niemand die Notwendigkeit, auch wenn's die natürlich für urbane Ballungsräume wie bei uns definitiv nach wie vor gibt,
siehe dazu auch unsere Debatten in der Freakshow.
Ist übrigens auch, äh also was, äh ich weiß ja nicht, ob sie es wussten, aber in deutsche Mobilfunknetze oder einige deutsche Mobilfunknetzer setzen zum Beispiel auch auf so bis zu siebzig Prozent einfach Mikrowellenverbindungen
Also die haben gar keinen Kupfer. In der Erde liegen und diese Netze in in vielen anderen Ländern auch nicht. Und wir haben uns da mal
mache ja äh ein bisschen mit Mobilfunksicherheit. Äh da haben wir uns mal äh bei so einem,
Test in einem Land über Zugänge am an so 'ner Mobilfunk-Vasisstation Gedanken gemacht und da Sicherheitsvorschläge zu entwickelt
Und äh da wurde dann auch gesagt so, äh warte mal, wenn wir von der Sicherheit der Mobilfunkstation sprechen, dann sprechen wir eigentlich äh
in der Regel von Kupferdiebstahl, weil der größte Sorge war halt, dass die ganze Mobilfunkstation einfach weggetragen wird. Ähm und nicht so sehr, dass da jetzt einer,
das Ding hackt und so oder sich dann irgendwie in den LTE-Chor vorkämpft oder was auch immer. Na ja, ähm wir schweifen ab. Ähm,
was was wird passieren, wenn die FCC das macht? Wie gesagt, Horizon hat's zweitausendvierzehn schon mal weggeklagt, dass die FCC ihn da reingefunkt hat und ähm ATNT Horizon äh Wetzen natürlich jetzt auch schon die Messer.
Sind aber einigermaßen besorgt, weil ja Obama vor ein paar Monaten schon gesagt hat, dass genau die Entwicklung, die da jetzt stattfindet, von ihm politisch gewünscht ist. Aber der ATNT weiß Präsident Of Regulations,
der Herr ähm,
ist nach wie vor sicher, dass die FCC nicht das Recht hat, ohne das Internet, ohne vorherige Eingehende Marktanalyse,
Universaldienst zu.
Oh Gott.
Zumal das Netz, das ist interessant, zumal das Netz eher ein Informationsdienst sei, als ein Telekommunikationsdienst.
Aha. Deswegen sperren sie auch immer alle.
Ist, dass er das als,
Also dass er das überhaupt als Teams bezeichnet.
Ist geil.
Wenn die FC,
Die unklassifizierung vor einem Berufungsgericht verteidigen muss, wird sie sich mit diesen und anderen Argumenten auseinandersetzen müssen. Mit anderen Worten äh,
das,
ihr landet damit sofort wieder vor vom Berufungsgericht klar. Ja? Das lassen wir uns nicht gefallen. Das ist ein Markthemmnis. Wobei uns ja in den Kommentaren gesagt wurde, wir sollen nicht mehr von Markthemnissen sprechen, sondern von Allgemeinheitsschutz.
Sagte der Peter.
Sagt der das. Warum?
Ja, also das wäre dann ein Netzneutralität wäre ein Allgemeinheitsschutz,
und ein Markthemmnis und da hat natürlich der äh der Cheflobbyist gegen Regulierung bei ATNT natürlich ähm was gegen und ein Anwälteteam dran gesetzt, ist klar.
Die USA. So ist sie. Ja, sonst äh.
Beste Demokratie.
Ja, aber äh unsere Telekommunikationsanbieter sind ja auch mit allen Wassern äh gewaschen und gehen mit dem,
mit dem Trend. So auch die Deutsche Telekom, die äh freudig verkündet hat, dass ihre Kapazitäten am deutschen Internetknoten DECICS,
erhöht hat, wenngleich da wohl auch ein wenig mit der Nase gerümpft wurde, weil so das Maß an Kapazitätserhöhungen eher überschaubar war.
Tim, verzwanzigfacht.
Das heißt halt nix. Wir waren ja vorher quasi nicht da.
Sie hatten äh sie hatten einen Gigabit Port da liegen. Was erzählt Clemens immer, dass das hat sie irgendwie in Skandinavien hat das jeder zu Hause, ne?
Ja, genau. Jetzt haben sie zwanzig Gigabiten alle so lustig. Wir schieben hier durch die Gegend. Was was wollt ihr denn eigentlich?
Also die Deutsche Telekom, wir erinnern uns, sie, die Deutsche Telekom äh begreift sich als Big Player.
Im Netz und äh und ein Big Player, ein ein Tier eins, ein Tier One,
ähm der piert natürlich nur mit seinesgleichen.
Die gibt's ja nicht.
Naja, es gibt ja schon noch drei oder sowas, ne, aber äh die die dipieren also nur mit den mit den ganz, ganz Großen,
und von den anderen, von den anderen verlangst du halt Transit, den von denen nimmst du Geld ab. Und wir erinnern uns, als diese ganzen NSA Geschichte losging, da war ja dann die Rede von von Schlandnetz und Schengenrouting.
Das waren ja die Stichworte. Die wurden ja auch von von der Telekom damals so reingebracht, weil die Telekom man sagte, ja. Das wäre doch super, wenn wir einfach innerdeutsch ruten, weil,
Wir erinnern uns, dass auch das hatten wir damals ausführlich erklärt. Clemens hatte das erklärt. Ich hatte das beim dreißig C drei auch in meinem Vortrag nochmal ein bisschen. Ähm,
behandelt. Die Datenpakete gehen ja nicht aus Deutschland raus und wieder nach Deutschland rein, weil da kein Kabel lege,
sondern weil die Deutsche Telekom einfach zu viel für die Benutzung davon dieser Kabel haben möchte, dass es den Leuten zu schwer macht, die zu benutzen. Also passiert, dass deutsche Anbieter.
Sich das Ganze billiger bei Level drei oder bei anderen äh großen äh organisieren,
Das Internet, die Verbindung mit dem Restinternet und dann bezahlst du natürlich nur einen dieser großen ähm,
Ähm das heißt, was weiß ich, ich ich als kleiner Deutscher,
Internetanbieter muss irgendwie zusehen, dass ich auch das ganze Internet erreichen kann. Also kaufe ich mir Kapazität oder Transit oder was auch immer bei Level drei und dann komme ich überall hin.
Und die Deutsche Telekom macht mir ein Konkurrenzangebot, das ist aber teurer und deswegen nutze ich das nicht. Und,
Ist natürlich für die Deutsche Telekom entgangener Gewinn und deswegen wollen sie natürlich eigentlich schon ganz gerne ähm dass,
die Leute bei ihnen irgendwie sich anschließen,
die gleichzeitige Entwicklung war aber natürlich die des DCX als inzwischen, glaube ich, weltweit größten Internet Exchange oder ist es immer noch nur Europas,
Internet Exchange.
Dezix ist jetzt wohl der größte ja weiß ich nicht wie das in Asien aussieht. Ich glaub sie sind die Größten. Aber also sie spielen auf jeden Fall ganz oben in der ersten Liga mit. So viel ist klar.
Und da sich dann was dann passiert ist, da haben sich einfach alle dahin gelegt und beim Dezix einmal bezahlt und dann stecken sie da an,
So vorstellen, ne, an einem großen,
Netz, also wie so ein großer Router, ist natürlich sind natürlich ganz viele Switches, aber sie stecken halt an die stecken da jetzt wenigstens mal dran und dann können sie sich mit den, mit allen, die da dran stecken,
auf äh einigen. Und da hat die Telekom auch ein Kabel liegen und.
Dass dessen Kapazität wurde jetzt halt von einem ein Gigabyte-Kabel Gigabit-Kabel auf zwei zehn Gigabit Ports äh erweitert. Und ähm.
Jetzt sagt die,
Telekom sehr stolz dazu, in einer Pressemitteilung. Da das Netz der Telekom mit fast allen großen Netzbetreibern direkt zusammengeschaltet ist, benötigte sie die größere Präsenz am Dezix eigentlich nicht,
Haltung früher. Allerdings hatten andere Anbieter eine verstärkte Nutzung des Netzknotens als Voraussetzung für die Realisierung des Internets der kurzen Wege definiert.
Mit anderen Worten, die die haben halt gesagt, wir liegen am Dezex. Wenn ihr euch da auch hinlegt, dann können wir uns verbinden und dann ist gut. Und das Alternativangebot der Telekom war ja, ja, wir haben ja unser Internet liegt ja woanders,
Aber das Kabel dahin, das kannst du bei uns mieten. Gar kein Problem. Dann können wir im Internet der kurzen Wege hier bei uns,
bei der Telekom machen. Und da haben die anderen Anbieter natürlich gesagt, nee, komm, hier, mach mal,
Aber ist sehr schön, wie sie das da so andere das jetzt definiert. Ja, gut, dann beugen wir uns dem natürlich. Die Telekom schlägt jetzt vor, dass sich alle Anbieter darauf,
Selbstverpflichten, also Selbstverpflichtung, habt ihr Zahl so dazu geschrieben. Daten ohne Umwege durch andere Rechtsräume vom Sender zum Empfänger zu leiten.
Im Netz der Telekom ist das Internet der kurzen Wege schon heute realisiert,
Die Telekom will weitere Partner für dieses Modell gewinnen. Es ist so geil, wie dieses Schild, ja? Im im Netz der Telekom ist das Internet der kurzen Wege schon heute realisiert. Natürlich
in jedem bei mir zu Hause ist das Internet der kurzen Wege auch realisiert. Wenn mein mein Server mit meinem oder mit meinem
iPad oder hat der Geier was gesehen redet, dann ist das Internet der kurzen Wege. Vom Wohnzimmer über den Flur ins Schlafzimmer,
Also das ist echt geil, was also das ist ein ein PR-Sprich. Ähm wunderbar. Die Telekom will weitere Partner für dieses Modell gewinnen.
Und wenn man sich anschaut, was sie denn da beim Dezix äh stehen haben, da steht dann Pearing Policy. Ähm mit anderen Worten, sie werden wahrscheinlich da jetzt ähm,
weiter versuchen, irgendwie Geld zu verlangen. Ja, also ich glaube nicht, dass sie da jetzt halt offen pionieren mit allen und sagen, hey, die Daten müssen frei sein. Denn steht in dieser Pressemitteilung überhaupt nichts drin, da steht nur
Ja, Verzwanzigfachung der Kapazitäten und gegen die Abhörbarkeit und hier äh,
Internet der kurzen Wege. Also das ist schon echt ähm ja.
Internet kurzen Wege.
Unglaublich, ja? Also weil Lichtgeschwindigkeit, Lichtgeschwindigkeit, Freunde, wir können die wir können das Glas echt dreimal ohne den Äquator legen, das ist uns völlig egal, ja. Na ja, okay.
So sind sie.
Es ist es ist natürlich nicht schlecht, aber wir müssen halt mal schauen, was die jetzt daraus machen und wie sie jetzt versuchen, die anderen, die am liegen, irgendwie äh zu melken. Äh wenn, weil nichts anderes wird die Telekom letztendlich,
damit vorhaben. Wer jetzt mal so meine bösartige Unterstellung.
Aber vielleicht belehrt sie uns da auch eines Besseren. Vielleicht wird das Internet der kurzen Wege dann äh bald äh Realität.
Kommen wir ähm zur Innenpolitik.
Ja, da gab's eine eine sehr interessante,
Ein sehr interessantes Vorkommnis im BND Untersuchungsausschuss. Ähm diese Woche war das, glaube ich, ne, diese Sitzung. Und zwar tauchten da auf der Gerhard Schindler, der Chef des BND.
Und der Geheimdienstkoordinator im Kanzleramt Claus-Dieter Fritsche.
Die beiden waren im BND Untersuchungsausschuss. Äh im im äh NSA und Geheimdienst und BND Untersuchungsausschuss. Und haben sich dann da hingesetzt und haben,
freimütig, so steht es geschrieben, über eine bisher unbekannte Operation Ads äh berichtet.
Und das in einer erstaunlichen Detailtiefe bisher war man ja äh dann gewohnt, dass irgendwelche.
Reden wir jetzt von der öffentlichen Sitzung oder reden wir von einer nichtöffentlichen.
Muss das muss die war eine nicht der nichtöffentliche Teil der Sitzung. Ähm bisher kannte man ja nur die ähm,
Die Techniker, die dann in der öffentlichen Sitzung oder die die Abteilungsleiter, die dann in der öffentlichen Sitzung immer gesagt haben, ja, da habe ich aber leider jetzt grade gar keine Aussagegenehmigung zu dem Thema, über das wir hier die ganze Zeit sprechen,
und was auch.
Nicht öffentlich.
Öffentlich, genau.
Nö. Da sage ich nur zu nö.
Und jetzt setzten sich also ähm Fritsche und Schindler,
in die nichtöffentliche Sitzung und berichte in den erstaunlicher Detailtiefe von einer Operation, von der der NSA BND Untersuchungsausschuss noch gar nicht wusste,
Hatten die nie von gehört.
Mhm.
Und diese Sitzung war auch nicht vorher als geheim eingestuft worden,
Was dazu führte, dass so die Mitarbeiter der Abgeordneten im Raum saßen, mit dem Raum saßen und auch die, die nicht die sonst erforderliche Sicherheitsprüfung hinter sich.
Kurze äh kurze Anekdote,
Wenn man in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss sitzt oder in dieser Untersuchung in Ausschüssen grundsätzlich, sitzen an einem runden Tisch, sitzen die.
Die Politiker, die Mitglieder dieses Ausschusses sind, was weiß ich, ne? Da sitzt dann Konstantin von Notzda und ähm in der Regel so hinter denen,
sitzen dann die Mitarbeitern,
ein, zwei Mitarbeiter oder halt der Mitarbeiter, den sie mit dem Thema betraut haben. Und das ist dann, das sind dann diejenigen, die äh natürlich einen großen Teil der, der politischen Arbeit
des Abgeordneten im Hintergrund dann erledigen, ne? Dessen, dessen direkte Mitarbeiter. Die sitzen da,
So, wenn diese Mitarbeiter jetzt in die geheime äh in die,
nichtöffentlichen Teile oder indiger als geheim eingestuften Teile der Sitzungen des Ausschusses möchten, müssen sie vorher eine Sicherheitsüberprüfung über sich ergehen lassen, die durchgeführt wird, wenn ich mich nicht täusche vom Verfassungsschutz.
Also der muss mindestens noch auch nochmal sein äh Senf dazu abgeben. Ich weiß nicht, ob die allein nicht zuständig sind.
Dann bekommen sie halt stimmt, das ist ein längerer Prozess, aber dann bekommen sie halt irgendwann Clearens.
Oder auch nicht.
Oder auch nicht. Und das kann sich natürlich auch mal hinziehen. Und das ist natürlich auch ein politisches.
Der bietet sich natürlich auch die Möglichkeit eines politischen Mittels da vielleicht diese Prüfung,
hinzuziehen und dann nochmal die Leute dahin zu bestellen oder Einwände irgendwie ausräumen zu lassen oder so,
Und das hätte natürlich zur Folge, wenn man das jetzt mit jemandem machen würde, dass diese Person eingeschränkt arbeits,
fähig wäre, für für ihren Einsatzbereich. Und das hätte natürlich dann auch zur Folge, dass die Arbeit der Abgeordneten an dieser Stelle ähm eingeschränkt würde, ne.
Aber es dient ja der Sicherheit. Ich erzähle das nur mal hier äh so am Rande. Das ist das ist das, dass es da auch so theoretische Fälle geben könnte. Ähm.
Und diese alle, also auch Leute ohne Sicherheitsüberprüfung sitzen da jetzt am,
am Tisch und hören das alles. Und dann schließen der liebe Herr Fritsche und der liebe Herr Schindler ähm,
damit, dass sie sagen, oh und das, was wir euch jetzt gerade erzählt haben, das darf unter keinen Umständen an die Öffentlichkeit, unter keinen Umständen darf das an die Öffentlichkeit geraten.
Das ist so brisant. Da äh da hört der sofort auf mit uns zusammenzuarbeiten. Und dann sind wir blind,
hier die die Selbstmordattentäter demnächst. Unter keinen Umständen darf davon irgendwas an die Öffentlichkeit geraten. Tschü.
Und so sitzen halt dann die die Abgeordneten da,
die nicht sicherheitsüberprüften Mitarbeiter und die Sicherheitsüberprüften Mitarbeiter und haben jetzt gerade von einer Operation gehört, von der sie nie zuvor gehört haben.
Jetzt ist die Frage, haben sie sich diese Operation einfach nur ausgedacht, um dann Testballon zu starten? Oder war die Operation vielleicht doch nicht so brisant, wie sie es geschildert haben? Weil sie mussten ja damit rechnen,
da irgendwas rausliegt aus dieser Sitzung. Und die Vermutung ist jetzt, dass auch genau das ihre Absicht war oder ihre Erwartung war, dass da was rausliegt und dass sie jetzt ähm.
Quasi Material sammeln von einem Hinweis auf die.
Auf die Gefährdung der geheimdienstlichen Tätigkeit durch diesen Ausschuss. Denn was als nächstes passierte, der Fokus.
Hat über diese Operation geschrieben. Fokus ist dieses.
Ehemalige Magazin.
Das war noch zu keinem Zeitpunkt jemals ein Nachrichtenmagazin. Das ist ein also ein absolutes also das ist wirklich die,
Bildzeitung unter den Bravos
Das ist ein ein wirklich ein ganz fürchterliches Hetzerblatt, was regelmäßig gegen ähm gegen Ausländer und ähm für irgendwie verstärkte Sicherheit und was nicht alles hetzt, ja? Also
ähm
Ich muss leider regelmäßig diesen Titel sehen, weil die das immer am Flughafen an der in der Auslage haben. Dieses dieses Magazin. Ich habe irgendwann mal den Fehler gemacht beim Flug in
Urlaub mir das mitzunehmen mit fürchterlicher Stimmung im Urlaub angekommen. Aber das nur am Rande. Also der Fokus, der nun wirklich ähm,
von jedem Verdacht befreit ist, irgendwie ein investigativ arbeitendes, aufklärerisches Magazin zu sein, ausgerechnet der tut jetzt quasi,
so ist die Form, so ist die Verschwörungstheorie. Ähm dem BND,
und dem Bundeskanzleramt den Gefallen dem Ausschuss zu attestieren, dass er nicht,
dicht halten könne. Und es steht jetzt der Verdacht im Raum.
Dass das ein abgekartetes Spiel war und vielleicht sogar diese Informationen gezielt von Bundeskanzleramt und oder BND an den Fokus gelangt sind.
Damit darüber berichtet würde, auf dass man Argumente für eine Einschränkung oder Beschränkung dieses Ausschusses haben könnte.
Das heißt, sie haben sozusagen ein eine Operationsinformation geopfert, um hier einen Testballon steigen zu lassen. Das ist die Vermutung.
Wäre aber schon ein bisschen heftig, wenn's äh so wäre. Weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie einfach das nur verkackt haben und irgendwie äh dachten, das wäre jetzt alles sicher, aber war's nicht. Das ähm kannst du das ausschließen? Nein, kannst du auch nicht.
Dass dass es genauso ist, wie sie gesagt haben, wir dass sie ein Geheimnis erzählt haben und jemand das dem Fokus geliebt hat, halte ich für unwahrscheinlich,
Wenn es jetzt in der Tat gestanden hätte oder auf Netzpolitik org, ja, dann hätte ich halt gesagt, na ja okay, aber bei.
Ausgerechnet beim Fokus, ich meine, unter dem Hinweis, unter dem Hinweis darüber.
Vor Ort gehabt.
Das weiß ich nicht. In der in der nichtöffentlichen Sitzung natürlich nicht.
Ja
Aber also ein ein kleiner ähm Hinweis so auf die grundsätzliche Position des Fokus in dieser Angelegenheit. Unter dem Hinweis auf diese Geschichte verlinkt der Fokus ähm,
dieses Video erklärt,
wie Geheimdienste uns vor Terroristen und kriminellen Ausländern schützen, so ungefähr, ja? Also der Fokus ist da absolut auf Seiten der der äh der Geheimdienste, Sicherheitspolitiker und Bundesregierung.
Dass deswegen ist diese also wie uns Geheimdienste vor Terrorwaffen und Rauschgift schützen.
Ausgeknüpft.
Rauschgift. Weißt du, wusstest.
Die sagen immer noch Rauschgift, oh Gott. Oh Mann oh Mann.
Allein dieses Wort.
Chillen, Geheimdienst, Eklat. Briten drohen mit Abbruch aller Kontakte zu Deutschland.
Deswegen jetzt oder was? Was war denn, was war denn das überhaupt für eine Operation, von denen sie da erzählt haben? Also da noch.
Bin doch nicht verrückt und verbreite die jetzt. Es ist also die zu verbreiten ist ja, also sorry, die zu verbreiten,
Würde ja nur in deren Hände spielen, ja, also das,
So oder so wär's so, ne. Sie haben darum, sie haben gesagt, das muss geheim bleiben und sie haben selber ihre, ihre Opsek äh Regeln massiv verletzt, indem sie das in einer nicht geheimen Sitzung veröffentlicht haben. Aber da tue ich ihnen jetzt nicht den Gefallen, ihnen das,
Argumente dafür zu liefern, warum.
Eine ähm derartige Bericht, warum die Öffentlichkeit dieses Ausschusses weiter beschränkt werden müsse. Abgesehen davon stehen diese Informationen nur im gedruckten Fokus und den fasse ich mit der Kneifzange nicht an.
Mir kann's, mir kannst du's doch sagen, weil doch keiner zu hier. Machen wir dann nachher.
Machen wir nachher. Ähm genau.
Das ist gleichzeitig stellen wir fest, dass es ja immer wieder äh unmissliebig,
Äußerung der Missliebkeit darüber gibt, dass Netzpolitik ORG diese Live Block äh Nummer macht aus dem aus dem Ausschuss. Sie sagen, ja, das kann ja nicht sein, dass das immer wieder alles in der Presse landet. Also sie.
Machen da immer weiter. Also sie wollen das einschränken. Und dann fragt man sich natürlich, warum sie ausgerechnet ausgerechnet die höchsten,
ähm.
Tiere daraus marschieren und und irgendwie mal frei aus dem Nähkästchen plappern. Und am Ende sagen, ach äh übrigens, psst! Das riecht schon ein bisschen.
Riecht ein bisschen. Nino, was ham wir's? Für die Woche.
Wir haben's, weil ja die nächste Sendung relativ bald kommt und wir dann da nochmal ein bisschen was da was zu machen.
Genau. So sieht's nämlich aus. Also haben wir euch.
Schade, dass du nicht auf diese schöne Verschwörungstheorie so eingesprungen bist, wo doch alles diese Woche im im Namen der Verschwörung steht.
Ist das so?
Ja, wegen dieser Metrolaut äh mit Frank.
Irgendwie ihre dreiundzwanzig ich habe ja meine dreiundzwanzigste Sendung schon äh ist ja schon eine Weile her. Da kann ich auch nochmal was.
Ja, du hast Recht, das waren, das hätte man noch dazu sagen müssen. Äh, Kalle Kornblumen und John F Nebel haben sich der Verschwörung gewidmet, weil sie die dreiundzwanzigste Folge ähm produziert.
Ja, das ist ja ein altes Meme, das äh hatten wir ja schon bei Chaos-Radio. Ich weiß nicht, ob du mit Kausradio dreiundzwanzig vertraut bist, wo wir heute schon so fleißig am Pluggen äh sind, von allen Ausgaben. Ich finde, das war eine Meisterleistung. Da waren wir noch richtig gut drauf. Da waren wir noch jung, da wollten wir noch was.
Radio dreiundzwanzig muss verlinkt werden.
Machen wir. Könnt ihr euch mal anhören, wenn ihr das noch nicht kennt. Das ist äh sehr verwirrend. Die Leute sind auch wirklich auf dem Zahnfleisch gelaufen und waren echt kurz vorm Durchdrehen.
Mir seitdem doch nicht wieder gelungen ist. Mal schauen, sollte ich vielleicht dran arbeiten.
Können wir noch was empfehlen? Nee, jetzt hören wir auf mit.
Wir können eine Menge empfehlen, aber jetzt hat sich's erstmal aus äh empfohlen, denn wir müssen ja diese Sendung auch noch aus hier unserem Private in den äh Großeltern bringen, ne?
Ja. Und man könnte unsere Sendung ja mal empfehlen. Ja, könnten, könnte ja auch mal jemand machen.
Du meinst, es blockt ja keiner über uns?
Wie sollen wir denn unsere Zwangs unsere Kapazitäten am zwanzigfachen.
Das stimmt allerdings. Genau.
Da ist jetzt, da ist jetzt richtig Platz. Das haben wir übrigens gerade nur am.
Genau, wir müssen das jetzt alles mit Logbuch Netzpolitik füllen, was jetzt da an neuen Kapazitäten bereitgestellt.
Mit unseren kleinen Fritzboxen.
Ähm du hattest das, glaube ich, kurz.
Leute ja auch äh uns immer gerne äh unterstützen und äh jenseits der Amazon äh äh Wunschlisten und sonstigen äh Spendenkanälen kann ich auch einfach nur sagen
empfehlt uns doch einfach mal weiter.
So, also äh schreibt doch mal dadrüber, äh twittert es, keine Ahnung, was auch immer eure Kanäle sind oder empfehlt auch nur anderen äh Freunden doch mal sich hier äh einzuklinken. Denn hier finde ich, ist es ja durchaus informativ und unterhaltsam.
Bei informativ gebe ich mir Mühe, bei unterhaltsamen auch, war stets bemüht.
Ja, ich auch. Ich sage tschüss. Bis bald.
Tschau, tschau.